hey guys
i've got an interesting video for you
today
a lot of guys are trying to figure out
this question how do you impress a girl
you like now there are videos about this
out there right but they are mostly the
same because they just repeat what
they've heard the same silly
stereotypical advice like oh you got to
be a bad guy or you got to have good
pickup lines
or you have to dress up this way or that
way most of these videos they miss the
point of it all the point of how the
world and people actually work let's
just focus on the outside superficial
things instead of focusing on the deeper
inner truths of reality so let me
quickly share with you eight tips of how
to attract the right type of girl for
you
don't try to act like a tough guy or a
badass especially if you are actually a
stand-up guy a guy with a good character
with good values and good morals
i'm not saying that you should be a
pushover here
what i'm saying is this you can be bold
confident and a decent guy as well
someone that other people will look up
to and respect
if you act like someone else then you're
actually lying about who you are
and then you'll attract the wrong type
of girl who won't be a good fit for you
anyway so why do it
focus on being the right guy before you
want to meet the right girl because you
don't want to meet the right girl
that's special that's honest
that's loving that is the
the girl of your dreams but then you are
not ready yet
flowers will attract bees there are
certain laws that will just always stay
true in nature
so if you are a guy
a stand-up guy with good manners good
grooming good values great work ethic
humble but confident disciplined healthy
a man of your word and someone that
loves life with no big issues no red
lights then you will impress the right
girl
impressing the right girl the girl of
your dreams it's about all these things
that work together
it's not just about one or two things
like
having a cool pickup line or
wearing the best leather jacket no
look at yourself in the mirror and be
honest will you date you
if you think about your personality your
character your values everything that
you are the way that you carry yourself
your manners
will a girl date you
if you don't even like certain things
about yourself then it's time
to look in the mirror be honest and to
work on yourself first
don't just jump into the wrong
relationship
and don't go through girls like you go
through take away don't go from the one
relationship to the other to the other
and to the other
don't get into a relationship quickly
don't do things like the rest of the
world and don't use their advice when it
comes to relationships because have you
seen how messed up the world really is
in the united states there's one divorce
around every 36 seconds
that's nearly 2 400 divorces per day and
every time you got through another
failed relationship you take all that
baggage with you
into the next one you might trust people
less
you might be more selfish you might have
less self-confidence as well this
this is real talk guys and please listen
to me if you're still young especially
because i've been through some of what
i'm talking about
and don't listen to celebrities as well
they might look cool the things that
they do the movies they play in but
their real lives when it comes to
relationships most of them have no idea
how to have healthy relationships
britney spears was married to jason
alexander for only 56 hours eddie murphy
and tracy edmunds for only two weeks now
most of them are in and out of
relationships just like people eat fast
food lana turner was married eight times
jerry lee and richard pryor seven times
tony curtis six times most of them went
through one to three divorces
like hail barry three times demi moore
three times take your time
work on yourself first and then when you
do find someone that you really like
take your time don't rush into things
get to know her first because
you might not really know her
people always show you at the beginning
what they want you to see
talk about her a lot more than you talk
about yourself
a lot of selfish guys they tend to talk
about themselves a lot how they feel
about certain things how they see
certain things how they think what they
will do their plans their career it's
just me me me me me very selfish they
forget to actually care about the girl
that they're talking to if you're
thinking too much about yourself it
shows and she can clearly see it and she
will feel as if you're more interested
in yourself than in her now i've said
this in other videos but i'll say it
again
people will usually always forget what
you've said
but they will never forget how you made
them feel and women
they feel a lot
they feel a lot with their emotions
and this is very important so listen
carefully every woman wants to feel
special understood attractive safe
secure appreciated respected prioritized
validated and
loved
she gives you the opportunity to start
that first conversation if you're
through the door then focus a lot more
on what she needs instead of thinking
about what you need think about it
you get together one day you want her to
be able to say you know i still remember
the feeling i felt when i first talked
to you
be a fun guy look you don't have to be a
funny guy because not everybody can be a
funny guy just be a fun guy to be around
with that's what most women look for i
mean just think about it just for
yourself
do you like it to be with a woman that
is always negative and no fun to be
around with of course not so live a
little and enjoy life be light-hearted
and make the most out of life be
adventurous try new things and invite
her to do it with you
especially if you know that she would
love to do bungee jumping or learn
surfing mountain climbing skydiving or
diving
talk less and listen more you know back
when i met my wife nikita i only spoke
one word to her
a lot of guys they just talk too much
and they forget about their nonverbal
communication
back in the day when i when i met nikita
i saw her on the dance floor and i just
looked at her you know
every now and then i would look up
and all i needed from her was just
one look just seeing that i'm looking at
her and then just smile a little bit or
a look of approval and once i got that i
knew
so i danced over to her
and went over and i just looked at her
and i just
showed her my hand i asked her to dance
with me without saying a word
she took it we danced and i just looked
at her the whole time in her eyes
connection
and all i said then was
hello
so i told her basically that i see her
from all the other people that's there
i see her
so show more with her actions and less
with your words abigail van buren said
the less you talk the more you're
listened to
ask the right questions
look you might like a certain girl but
that doesn't mean that you will like her
as a wife later do you remember what i
said earlier in the video that most
people just show you what they want you
to see about them at the beginning right
so you might not know them at all but
with time later on you get to see
different sides of them that you never
knew so don't just think about i want to
impress her
think about i want to get to know her
better so when you do talk to her not a
lot but when you do talk to her ask the
right kind of questions if you ask the
right kind of questions you will steer
the conversation in the right way in the
right direction thomas kuhn said the
answers you get depend on the questions
you ask
pray
a lot of you thinking man daniel's
joking praying for a girl
yes pray i'm not joking i'm being honest
here
this is the best advice that i can give
you i made a lot of mistakes when it
came to relationships
caused a lot of hurt i got hurt
and the problem is this
you can't go back in time and fix it
you can only ask forgiveness learn from
your mistakes and move on
and man broken relationships
there's a lot of people that go through
unnecessary pain
as i did
and i don't want you to make the same
mistakes
that i made so my advice to you is to
honestly pray to god for guidance
direction and strength
ask god to send you the right woman
because he created you and he knows who
your wife should be a perfect fit don't
get into the wrong relationship if you
think that this relationship won't lead
to marriage then what are you doing
you're wasting time you're causing hurt
or you're just waiting to cause a hurt
don't
don't do it wait for the right girl and
then marry her and even then you'll see
the honeymoon phase
it won't always last marriage is hard
work and if you're not married then
listen to me carefully today because if
you marry the wrong woman
you'll either have like
hell on earth
or heaven on earth if you marry the
right woman the bible says an excellent
wife who can find she is far more
precious than jewels this is just some
personal advice
that i've learned
through all the mistakes that i did
there's no relationship that can work
without god in it
do you know why
because only god
knows what is true love
the love that we have that we feel it
came from god in the first place because
god is love one john 4 7 says beloved
let us love one another for love is from
god and whoever loves has been born of
god and knows god anyone who does not
love does not know god because god is
love
now if you want to know what the
husband's role is in the marriage and
the wife's role in marriage in a
christian marriage and watch these
videos here from my other channel and
i'll see you there and before you go
always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys